俺の名前は肇社長
ユーチューバーをやっている
youtube の世界は目立ってナンボ
だからユーチューバーが髪の毛や見た目を気にする奴が少なくない
俺もう久しぶりに髪の毛を染めてみた
銀色にな銀色のカミーノしているユーチューバーはほぼ見たことがないし
実際よりも銀色にしてから願っているだろう
だが銀髪の寿命は短い髪の毛に色を入れた人ならわかると思う
色は用いる
そして銀色は
特にオチやず
そう
もうかなり間が抜けてきたなぁ
最初はめっちゃくちゃ気だったんやー
嘘1週間でこんなに抜けんのだよ
気に入ってたのになぁちょっと塗装しちまえよああああ
ただ
[音楽]
ていた
me
虫取り乗った
[音楽]
これは矢部銀髪の俺マジかっけー
ちょっと色落ちちゃったけどまだ銀色でいたいなと思うはず目の心といやいやや夏所夏
夏といえば金髪
た手紙である日で暴れ大勢ウェイと思っているはじめの心が対立し
2つの心が具店
され今まさにはじめの心の中で戦っている状態なのである
かっこいいそんなに長く持たないカミーロなんて非効率だよ
フォア真面目
ちょっとの銀髪に7枚まあ
うるさい
去年は金箔にしたんだよ
それには前 twitter の評判も良かったぞ銀髪の画像なんて6000円程度だ
どうだジョン何気なくまたねカミーノなんで引越いつだよ
声恥ねー
ドットと金髪に島をせ
[拍手]
それでもオレはー
今年の夏は
引っ張っていきたい何が書店は1週間以
の
は金髪だったら色落ちもしないぞ俺はギヤを広めない
この無駄崎チャンプ
そしてこの村すげえロッドショット長すぎるを超えマニックパニックを使えば
俺の銀ロードシーズはまだつつガッター
ダメだよそんな髪色者
言えばキー早速そんなへのを取っちまえ
あっはっ
そういえばお前の後半へ見てみろ
こりゃあハッハ頻発に村日はくるぜ
[笑い]
me
お前なんですが丈
そのままな金髪になっちまう
これ以上クリーチャーしてるん
ハゲずそんなの関係ねーよ
彼肌今の若泉楽しいんだぞねー
ポルたちの豪雨で冷笑なぁ
俺らお前なんかに負けないてくぞつまらないチャンス
そしてバリックバリック裏バエ8番イーサー
日間ってこういうはて清瀬めっちゃ怖いたフレッジ
ああああああ
あ
パッ
archi んじゃないか
ai
me
teap 2
んあっ
かかって来いはぜひを攻め主よホワイトズレ j
マジで出さない